what's our subject
a cut above the rest
if we will but listen god's
created works will teach us precious
lessons
of obedience and trust from the stars
that in their trackless courses
through space follow from age to age
their appointed path
down to the minutest atom the things of
nature
obey the creator's will and god cares
for everything
and sustains everything that he has
created
he who opens the unnumbered worlds
throughout immensity
at the same time cares for the wants of
the little brown spiral
that sings its humble song without fear
when men go forth to the daily toilet as
when they engage in prayer when they lie
down at night
and when they rise in the morning when
the rich man
feasts in his palace or when the poor
man
gathers his children about the scanty
board
all are tenderly watched by the heavenly
father
no tears are shed that god does not
notice
there is no smile that he does not mark
steps to christ page 85
paragraph four god is good
and all the time good evening everyone
it's nice to see you thank you very much
for coming to the house of god
to listen to his word i extend that
welcome to all those connecting online
whether by facebook
youtube whatever the method of
transmission is thank you for joining us
we welcome our sister church in missouri
city and of course
daytown report thank you for joining us
and i pray that the lord will bless us
with a revelation of truth because it's
truth alone
that sanctifies and the bible says that
jesus
is truth john 14 6 the father is truth
deuteronomy 32
4 and the holy spirit is truth first
john chapter 5 verse 6
in order to be the children of god we
must be
children of the truth can you say amen
our subject for today a cut above the
rest a cut
above the rest before i get into that
let me welcome anyone watching
who is not a seventh-day adventist if
you're online if you're with us somehow
god bless you thank you very much we are
delighted and honored by your presence
and may the lord truly and richly bless
you
let our heads and pray our father in
heaven we thank you so
much for preserving our lives we thank
you thank god for giving us clear minds
health that allows us to travel homes in
which we live
transportation to move back and forth
food to eat
and a relatively safe society in which
you live
and the ongoing presence of freedom of
worship
we thank you for these things and for so
much more if we've offended you forgive
us dear god
and grant us now the presence of your
spirit
that he may guide our minds into the
path of truth
i humble myself before you regard and i
ask in the name of jesus
a name you never resist speak through me
father
for your glory suppress all that is
carnal immediate god
that self may have no part in this
presentation
anyone listening to me has the cover 19
i ask you the name of jesus
deliver that person dear god heal that
person
just to be merciful lest every country
represented by those listening
particularly our host country of the
united states
bless the leaders god let them make
decisions that the lord the gospel to go
forward
thank you again for the privilege of
calling you father
and of coming into your presence through
christ i pray in jesus name
amen now let's look at some bible verses
some of which we have read before
what's our subject a cut above the rest
in other words different from everyone
else go to exodus 19
exodus 19 we'll read from verse 4 and i
will read from the king james version of
the bible
exodus 19 reading from verse
4. the second book of the bible should
be hard to find
chapter 19 as the chapter just before
the ten commandments are spoken on sinai
by the way it was spoken by jesus christ
himself before the father
because christ always functions as the
agent of the father exodus 19 verse 4.
this is the jesus speaking you have seen
what i did
unto the egyptians and how i bear you on
eagle's wings and brought you
unto myself now therefore
if ye will obey my voice indeed
and keep my covenant then there shall be
a peculiar treasure unto me
read the next few words above all
people which means that god saw
the israelites and everybody else
it may not sound politically correct but
it's biblical here were the israelites
and everyone else ye shall be a peculiar
treasure unto me
above all people for all the earth is
mine
and so that verse tells us that god
desired to have a people
that meant more to him than any other
people are godless of our world
when god called abraham in genesis 12 he
wanted him to be a blessing to all
nations
and the blessing was the passing of the
gospel through the seed of abraham
to the world so god always desires to
save the world but he called
a people through whom he would work and
he wanted them
separate from the rest of the world now
go to leviticus chapter 20 we read verse
26 our subject
are cut above the rest
very next book leviticus i believe i
told one of the three congregations the
key word in leviticus
is holiness which may be defined as
separation from the world of total
separation to god
you cannot be separated to god unless
you're separated from the world
leviticus 20 verse 26 when you found
that say amen
and ye shall be holy unto me for i
the lord am holy and have done what
separate you from other people why
that ye should be mine
we have a condition in that verse in
order to belong
to god we must be separated from the
world
and have severed you from other people
that ye should be mine
let's go to image chapter three
it was chapter three
we read verse two
the little books called the minor
prophet but his message was not minor
they are called the minded prophet
simply because they have very few
chapters in each
the longest of the minded prophets is
probably
imagine 14 chapters but the message
is not minor the major prophets are
isaiah
my ezekiel they are 50-plus chapters but
the others are called maya you have amos
chapter 3
verse 2 what does that say you
only have i know come on
of all of
all the family what god is the word
means love
remember the bible say adam you eat his
wife well i love expression that's what
it means
you only have i love when god says that
loves more than all
the families of the earth this is not my
word
the bible clearly teaches that god
wanted a relationship with the people
that was different from every other
people
having read those three verses exodus
leviticus 20 26 well those listen
to this quotations
papers and prophets page 126 paragraph 1
now that abraham was in a special sense
connected with heaven
he must dwell among strangers his
character
must be peculiar differing from
all the world
when jesus told the disciples in matthew
verse 48 ye are the light
of the world the correct assumption is
the world had no light
if the world had light there would be no
need to provide light
jesus said ye are the light of the world
first john chapter 5 verse 19 and we
know that we are of god
and the whole world lies in wickedness
or darkness
so we have two those in the light
those are darkness now let me say
quickly those in darkness are not all
lost
because jesus tells us in john 10 16
of the sheep i have which are not of
this fall their darkness
then also i must pray so not everyone in
darkness is lost
if that's clearly amen all right
and so everybody says in pages of
prophets page 1 26 paragraph one
abraham's character had to be peculiar
differing from all the world
having laid down that foundation let's
go to deuteronomy chapter 18
7 27 i'll let you up early tonight
doesn't take dog long to bless his
people
the longer i speak the more your mind
gets tired
is this natural situation that's the
wrong thing what
did i say deuteronomy 1 chapter 18
ready for one first nine before i read
let me pray again dear god
as i continue i'm appealing to you to
continue that god
to speak through me not for my sake
but for the sake of your glory and the
blessing of those listening
in the name of christ i pray amen
this now this passage let me set it up
is in deuteronomy as you've observed
the book of deuteronomy it contains
about three
major speeches given by moses
they were given at the end of the 40
years of wandering in the wilderness
they are on the banks they can see the
promised land they still need to cross
jordan
moses wants to remind them and rehearse
in the hearing
what god expected of them he reminds
them of all the struggles the trials the
tribulations
how god had delivered them he urges them
to lay aside
all anything that looks like idolatry
and to worship only the true god
who made heaven on earth he reminds them
what gives them laws to govern the
behavior of kings
priests prophets how they conduct war
the time
all of that then he tells them the
blessings of obedience
the curses of disobedience all of that
three major speeches
in the book of deuteronomy so this is a
reminder
to the people just before they go where
into canaan land now let me ask you this
who
inhabited canaan land
i'll wait for a few seconds and there's
several tribes called canaanites
the bible usually talks of seven nations
they have the canaanites the hittites
that's where they headed keep us in mind
to the land
overrun by adultery and hedonism keep
this in mind now
knowing that's where they headed god
instructs moses to remind them
of how they ought to behave now let's be
from verse 9 in deuteronomy 18.
when we come into the land which the law
thy god giveth thee
thou shalt not learn to do after the
abominations of those nations stop
the bible has sins and all sin
can get you lost if it is not confessed
are you following me
a little sin will get you lost if it's
not confessed a big sale will get you
lost
if it's not confessed adam said was not
mass murder
he only consumed a fruit but he
disobeyed god
and look at what happened to the earth
now another abomination now
is something that is particularly
disgusting to god
sin upsets god but an abomination
let me risk my life by giving an example
if an unmarried man and an unmarried
woman
get involved physically that's sin it's
a grievous sin in the eyes of god
but it is still a natural act did i lose
you
because god made women to be filled with
men but in the marriage counted
it is still a natural light now when a
man
married or not gets physically involved
with a man
that is an abomination are you with me
now
it is unnatural at every level then now
there are abominations and sins notice i
said all can get you lost
but some upset and disgust god more
than others now god tells israelites
when he come into the land
which i given to you ye shall not
learn to do after the abominations of
those nations let me tell you this
those nations have their religion
not only the israelites had a religion
the israelites came out of egypt
egypt had its religion of the varieties
of that religion when they worshipped
the golden calf in exodus 32
they most likely had seen the worship of
the egyptian god
in piss which was a bull
they must have observed the worship of
that bull
and so when they were in the wilderness
hadn't seen moses 40 days
they made what they had seen and they
worshipped a little boy a little castle
a little cow that's what they as a
matter of fact
if you really don't know now have your
pleasure read
ezekiel 20 where god pleaded
ezekiel is writing about the events in
egypt and the wilderness
and ezekiel writes the first twentieth
chapter of verse eight or chapter twenty
that the israelites refused to give up
the false gods
when god called them out but he said but
i
brought them out for my name's sake
they refused they were so conditioned
by faults and idolatrous worship they
remember rachel when she left labor
what did she have under the saddle false
gods
she had seen in label's house
that was her home she brought them with
her she was making true and false and
when laban said where my god she sat on
them
and he would not they would not allow me
to search the saddle because she said
well you know what she said
and so but they came up with these false
gods
years like brought false god to them
into the wilderness
but they were not on the scale as what
they're about to
witness god says this you
shall not learn to do
after the abominations of those nations
verse there
they shall not be found among you anyone
that made it his son or his daughter to
pass through the fire so
what do you call that child
sacrifice some of those tribes
practice child sacrifice and their bible
scholars who believed to some degree
at some point the israelites did the
same
not on a wide scale but they did the
god told them you see that land over
there they offer child sacrifices
they shall not be found among you anyone
that maybe their son or his daughter the
passage of fire
or that yusef divination you're going to
have someone read your palm
or read cards or someone throws some
bones on the ground and someone reads
the bones
god said don't do that or an observer of
times
or an enchanter or a witch or a charmer
or a consultant with familiar spirits or
a
wizard or a necromancer all these
religious
expressions were the ways by which the
heathens
interacted with the various gods when
they wanted to please their gods they
would offer human sacrifice
when they wanted to discover what the
god will have them to do they may go
to divination or observable times or go
talk to the dead
and be chromatic they were all related
to
the religious practices
god tells the israelites do not go to
them
to learn how to conduct your religious
rights
listen you hear my words i'm not sure if
you understand what i'm saying
let me make an abrupt shift
go to revelation
uh 18 revelation 18.
let's read verse 14 verse 4 sorry
got revelation 18
there's a loud cry and the loud cry
is directed at god's people in babylon
let me say it again the loud cry is
directed at god's people
in babylon who preaches the loud cry
god's remember church are you following
me they preach it
to bring those out of whom jesus said of
the sheep i have which are not of this
fall
them also let us bring this hear my
voice the loud cry
is designed to bring those in babylon
who are ignorant
and if they hear the truth they will
come
verse 4 revelation 18 what does that say
and i heard one avoid saying what unto
me what
come out of her my people come on
that he be not partaker of the sins and
that he receive not of the place keep
revealing
for her sins have reached unto heaven
and god has remembered her iniquities
now
this is a description of a religious
organization
i said that clumsily let me try again
when god said
come out of her he means come out of a
religious system
not come out of a casino a religious
system
let me be more bold god's greatest enemy
in revelation we know is the devil
but the devil's agent the most effective
agent he has
against the gospel is a religious system
a church or collection of churches that
come
under the name of babylon headed by one
particular church
and so we have a message calling god's
people
out of churches
if god calls me out of the church that
church has nothing to give me
i have lost you lost maybe i haven't
lost those online i lost you all right
let me try
let me try again let's reason together
if god tells me
to come out of that that you be not
partakers of a sins
and that you receive not of her place
there's nothing in there for my good
get out
god's major enemy on the earth
with respect to human system is a
religious
organization when the israelites were on
the banks of the jordan
looking at the promised land and moses
said thou shalt not
learn to do after the abominations of
those churches
verse 12 of uh
deuteronomy 18 are you there i'll let
you get back there
i'll take your hitchhiking through the
bible i'll let you get back to
deuteronomy 18
let's read first let's read from verse
10 again to remind you what god said
this shall not be found among you anyone
that it his son or his daughter
to pass through the fire by the way the
way we raise our children sometimes
as we pass them through the fire
i don't want to say much because uh
you can't change the past or the most
painful experience is to look at your
child and realize i raised that child
the wrong way and there is
nothing i can do to change it it's a
painful
experience and i don't want to provoke
not in anyone listening but i want to
say to you generally many parents
they pass their children to the fire
i remember this
man came to me perfect son
i said why i always ask why
there's some requests i don't pray about
and he told me why why pray
but i didn't think much would come out
of it
he had placed his son in an environment
that is
admired from a cultural perspective
but was spiritually destructive
but it's what people do to be cultured
and to the upper class
you expose yourself to this and that he
did that to his son
now the son was heading in the wrong
direction he wanted me to pray
we pass our children through the fire
by the way we reach them but i believe
that unpleasant subject alone
they shall not be found among you anyone
that makes his son
or his daughter the passion of fire or
that use a definition or an observable
time
or an intent or an enchanter or a witch
or a charmer or consult with familiar
spirits
in some parts of the world the advocates
who go to wish doctors they still do
to consult yes they do
they may not go to which doctors united
states they may go to a fortune channel
they may read a horoscope are you
following me that's no different
we may have what looks like most
sophisticated forms of spiritualism
and in other parts of the world it looks
more primitive but it is the same
they may read the fortune cookie from
the chinese restaurant and take it
seriously
the devil comes at us in little ways and
then grabs us
how big is the corona virus have you
ever seen a virus look at the damage it
does
nor a trauma nor consult a familiar
spirits in our
wizard nor he call battle for all that
do they say
reverse threat with me for all that what
do
they say are an abomination to the lord
keep remaining
and because of these abominations finish
the verse
the lord that god does drive them out
from before
why would the israelites go to get rid
of the canaanites
why did god drive them out because of
their religious
practices
not the economy
all the economies are dishonest if all
economies are dishonest
they were driven up because of their
religious
practices and god says you're my people
when you get in there
i want your behavior absolutely
different in other parts of the bible
god said
if you do what they do i will drive you
on
other verse 13 say he shall be one
perfect with the lord i god in others do
what's right
but these nations which thou shalt
possess
hearted under observers of times and of
the diviners but as for thee
the lord that god hath not suffered they
sought to do now read
verse 15 here's what god tells the
advice i will do for you
the the heathen they went about their
own ways trying to connect with their
gods
here is what god said he will do for his
people verse 15 read with me
the law thy god shall raise up unto thee
one a prophet come on from the midst of
the
of thy breathing light unto me and to
him
you shall hurt now god is telling don't
go to the witch doctor
don't go to defenders don't go to the
commanders witches wizards
though consulted with familiar spirit
charmers
those who observe time don't go there i
will provide a prophet
and he will speak for me to you
by combining that verse with verses 9
9-14 we realized
that the heathen nations had disgusting
ways
in trying to determine the will of their
gods
and god told the israelites he condemned
every one of the actions
and god drove them out what am i trying
to say to you
let's apply this to the state of the
atheist church
we've been called by god to preach a
message
no one of the speeches what's that
the three angels messages
and of course the loud cry which is
combined revelation 14
6-12 revelation 18 1-5 but all our truth
comes out of
daniel 8 14 under 2 300 days then shall
the sanctuary be cleansed
and elohic writes this is the foundation
text of this church
where we pray again father as i continue
be with me help me to make it
simple dear god that you're listening
people may realize your cause to be
different from every other church in
jesus name i pray
amen different from other church i don't
say it better than
that's not the judgment we make we just
say different
from are you following me all right
when christ came the first time
how many people knew
let's list them on one hand how many
people here
three wise men according to bible the
bible records
the shepherds found out because the
angels told them
only the three wise men having studied
were aware
that christ was coming as far as the
bible tells us now there are others in
the temple looking for his coming
you know that old lady name was anna and
simeon they were looking perhaps
they knew but those clearly presented as
knowing where the three wise men the
shepherds had no clue
until the angels told them what am i
trying to say there was a
nation on the face of the earth that
should have alerted the world
that the god who said let there be light
was on his way
as a human being
to live among us and to live the life
that the israelites should have lived
let me say differently the life jesus
lived is exactly what god wanted
the israelites in the old testament
because the same way israel is my son
jesus is god's son
and when we live the life of christ we
collectively
are god's son as israel was god's son in
back then
the seventh-day adventist church is
god's son today
but we are afraid to say that
now christ is coming the second time
someone has to be told the
responsibility
for telling has been placed upon us
because the message that prepares the
world has been given to us
have you ever heard a television
preacher preach the three angels
messages
the prosperity preachers no why do i
don't play because they cannot do it
not because this is the bible they can
read it but they cannot do it they have
not been called
they've not been commissioned
we have and if we don't do it
god will have to cause the stones to cry
out because
when it comes to the second time the
world has to know
because god has a people in error that
need to come out
the message of the three angels is not
designed to convert the world
it is designed to prepare the world for
the second return of christ
what it does it brings those in babylon
out
and those who hear the message they're
harder than the opposition to god
and the world is split into two caps and
those two camps are described in
revelation 14
because after the three angels messages
revelation 6 through 12
or 2 13 from 14 down to the end of that
chapter
we're dealing with two harvests
and i looked and behold a white cloud
revelation 14 14
and upon the cloud one satellite under
the son of man
having on his head a golden crown and in
his hand a sharp sickle
right after the three angels messages
are proclaimed and keep in mind
the third angel combined with the angel
of revelation 18
to present a lot of cry
when that's presented
many in babylon will come out
that's right should i tell you this
i'll tell you you're like brothers and
sisters
many years ago i read in elijah's
presence
i don't know the place now in the time
of trouble
some of god's people will be arrested
have taken the courts
and they will have to stand in court and
defend why they preach what they preach
and when they defend the truth people in
the courtroom listening
will take their stance to the truth and
i told the lord
i want to be one of those people
arrested
i didn't say one of those people causing
trouble i said those people are
arrested are you listing me that i might
because i want to see
the fulfillment of that prophecy i told
god i want to be one of those persons
arrested
to stand and defend the truth and see
people accept the truth as evan white
said
i want if the lord allows me to but i
told him
i want to do that i want to be arrested
i never said i want to cause trouble i
want to be arrested
that i might stand in the courtroom
defend present truth
and see the fulfillment of everyone's
prophecy
the three of those messages split the
world into two now
let's read verse 15 let's read 14 again
of revelation 14 and we'll read on from
there
it's now 7 49 i'll release you as soon
as i can
revelation 14 be written verse 14 let me
pray again
thank god help me to slow down please
and to speak
only the words you give me in jesus name
i pray
amen you have revelation 14
verse 14 you have my version what's my
version all right read from me what does
that say
and i looked and behold a white cloud
come on not upon the clown one set like
unto the son of man who's that
jesus christ having on his head one a
golden crown
in his hand a sharp circle that can be
quick the crown means he's not a king
he's not a priest he's a king some
churches preach when christ comes you
have a second chance of repentance
he's not coming as a priest it is the
priest that intercedes
is the king that conquers the rules are
you following me he is coming
as a king to overthrow his enemies and
deliver his people
the sickle in his hand suggests the
harvest he's coming to reap a harvest he
does the priest
carried a sensor with the incense
representing the merits of christ
the king carries a scepter he's coming
to reap the harvest
read verse 15 foreign
for the time has come for thee to read
for the harvest of the earth is right
there's no need for distance mercy
anymore the harvest is right
verse 16 and he that sat on the cloud
thrust in his circle in the earth and
the earth was ripped that's one harvest
you'll observe the last words of verse
15 the harvest
of the earth is right do you see that
you see that right a harvest is only cut
when it's right you read joel 3 verse 13
put you in the sickle for the harvest is
right okay
read verse 17 and another angel came out
of the temple which is in heaven
he also having one a sharp signal first
and another alien came out of thee all
the witch had one
power over and cried without crying to
him that heart the sharp sickle saying
what
thrust in the shop signal and gather the
customs of the vine of the earth
for her graves are fully ripe now we
have another set of rightness
read verse 19 and the angel did one
firstly sing on the earth and gather the
vine of the earth and cast it into the
white press of the one
into the one the wrath of god
so where does that harvest go
is the wrath of god where does that
harvest go
come on i'm not reading this until you
tell me if it is the wrath of god
where is that describe that harvest
so what's the harvest that's the last
that's the wicked now so then what is
the harvest
in verse 16 and 15.
the harvest of verses 15 16 represent
the righteous the harvest of 1819
represent
the lost but you'll notice the only
thing common to both
is that both are right
in other words there's nothing god can
tell me to get me to serve him
and there's nothing the devil can tell
me to get me to leave god
oh you didn't get it it's all good
it's over the wicked will remain with
you either is unjust come on
let it be on just still now who has been
commissioned
to preach this message the seventh-day
adventist church amen
amen now if that's the case
and god tells me come out of babylon
there's nothing bad love has to offer me
are you following me there is nothing
babylon
has to offer me there was nothing the
canaanites
had to offer the israelites and god said
get rid of them
there's nothing more tragic than an
egyptianized israelite
do you have an idea an israelite who
tries to live
like an egyptian i mean spiritually
it's a tragedy the first is refrain the
quotations we've read
clearly distinguish the fact that god
desires a people
who will be aware of the fact that they
are to be
different from the rest of the world
to reflect their savior that that
reflection
may attract people they are to be
a cut above the rest
they must not do what the israelites did
in 1st samuel 8
when they told samuel we want a king
samuel said why in verses 19 and 20
we want to be like the other
nations when joshua and moses came off
the mountain
joshua said there is a sound of war
in the camp moses said it's not war
it's the people worshipping or see
there's a kind of worship style that
sounds
like war and then there's a worship
that sounds like worship are you with me
i'm giving details i'm simply saying
when they were worshiping egyptian style
joshua thought it was war because joshua
was a warrior
this is born someone's attacking them
moses had to come right out of the
presence of god
he said no no joshua there worshipping
you in verse 19 i believe it is in
exodus 32 when moses came there
he drew an eye and sort of dancing and
yeah the dancing is in there he threw
down the two tables
and broke the why because he was viewing
egyptian worship remember that
moses spent 28 years growing up in the
egyptian courts
he was a general of the egyptian army
he knew that lifestyle and when he saw
it
i was in a certain country preaching and
i was having lunch in the family home
and the church member who would recently
learn ties was prison
and she came for those churches where
everyone speaks in tongues and they jump
and they shout
and she said when she came to the other
side she almost left
because she said wait a minute that's
what i left
that's what i left and here it is
she said she almost left but as certain
members rallied around her she continued
to be exposed to the truth
she stayed and she's glad she stayed but
she almost
left because she said i am seeing what
i left moses saw
what he had what he'd been accustomed to
to see not necessarily doing
but to see they were jumping and
shouting and playing and overeating and
dancing
and moses threw down and god told moses
tells the
device strap on this earth
leave my strap on this earth
ah god is love but god can he's been
fixed and pushed us in time
this is god's direction now those
levites were merely swords in the hand
before
thirty thousand nine and they started
repenting
conformity to babylon will never
convert better
look at me as though i need to say
differently
the blind says my words camel tell me
come on leave the blind
where are seven evidence we cannot
missions like this or services like this
to tell people god has a people on this
earth
and he's committed to them his law one
of their responsibilities
is to vindicate that law and to lift up
the faith of jesus
the reverse order although it comes in
revelation as the commandments of god
because
of jesus jesus always comes first but
you cannot separate christ from the lord
christ catholic
is the law god has a people
on this earth in largely events
page 43 paragraph 3 element writes
god has a distinct people a church on
earth
second to none and superior to all
in the facility to teach truth and to
vindicate the law of god
second to none and superior to all
and we're not called upon to be ashamed
of who we are
in uh testimonies volume five page four
fifty five paragraph two
seventy evidence have been chosen by god
as a peculiar people
separate from the world obama has called
this church in this way i should say
as he called ancient israel to stand as
a light in the earth
by the mighty cleveland of truth the
messages of the first
second and third angel he has separated
them
from the churches and from the world
god calls upon us to be different and
that difference must be biblical
and so we go back to deuteronomy 18
verse 9
when thou art come into the land with
the lord thy god given thee thou
shalt not learn to do after the
abominations of those nations
they have nothing to offer you
don't study the bible the way they do
don't worship the way they do
they have nothing to offer you that's
why i am
reading the land of them that you might
populate the land
and demonstrate the kind of lifestyle
that represents heaven
because you are to be to the earth a cut
above the rest my brothers and sisters
god is coming back for a people
who make christ their mortal and the
scriptures they stand
i repeat christ is coming for a people
who make christ the model and the bible
they stand and as jesus when he lived on
this earth people said
what manner of man is this we must live
so close to god
that people will say what manner of
people
are suffering their letters we make no
boast of being better
we simply have a mandate to be different
to be a cult above the rest
and tonight i call upon you to re-affirm
your commitment to the truth of
revelation 14
6-12 the three angels messages
that special message that god has given
to this church
how many people say with me father i
recommit myself to the proclamation of
that truth you've given to this church
can i see your hand
god bless you study it tomorrow
become familiar with it so you can teach
it
the three angels messages a message that
make
us a cut above the rest and for those of
you considering baptism you
you're considering the right name
because to be baptized is to be baptized
into
jesus and one who said come out of her
my people
is jesus the one who said urshy by half
which none of this fooled is jesus since
your decision
or your thought to be baptized is right
let that thought mature tonight right
now and confirm your decision
to be baptized into the truth
that you may be fully a child of god
because you cannot be a child of god
unless you're that way
fully let us pray our father in heaven
we thank you for your word
we thank you god you've called us father
to deliver a message
that is particular for this time a
message that will prepare the world
to receive the savior as verily as at
the first coming
virtually no one knew father we cannot
allow that tragedy
to attend the second coming of christ
help us to
recommit ourselves to the proclamation
of truth
between those messages that the world
may have a chance to say yes or no
because it is that message that divides
the world
into those for god and those who are the
enemy
father help us by our lives also to lead
people to you
i trust the words i spoke may god will
remain in the hearts of your people
let the meditator think that god and
understand
that the end of all things is at hand
take us home safely
bring us back tomorrow to hear your turn
on friday to hear your word again
we pray in jesus name amen
you